we've got all these stories about big
tech colluding for political reasons you
know DNC Democratic officials reaching
out to Twitter things like that but
there were there was also uh information
pertaining to restricting covid we
recently saw tweet I think the Hodge
twins tweeted at Elon and said did like
let me guess you saw a tweet between the
government and Twitter or discussing
censoring coveted information and they
posted a trophy so what's what's going
on with that you guys had something
recently right yeah so we've put out a
number of things a number of uh you know
press releases that turn into kind of
long articles folks can read through and
see themselves where we pull the
documents we get screen screenshots
screen grabs of the text I love folks
you know hey here it is here's so and so
government official talking to so and so
with this platform we've put a few
different things out and we're putting
these things out and we're going to
continue to do it on a rolling basis
because it's the result of a lawsuit
that we had to file against the
government to get this data out and so
every time we get a batch of data we're
trying to pull out there get the
Highlights you know bring it to folks
and let the American people see what was
going on behind the scenes so the latest
thing that we have here which is similar
to something else we had was this back
Channel reporting uh reporting Channel
at Twitter where government officials
were able to log in and flag information
that they deemed as misinformation for
Twitter employees
to purge from their system the same
thing existed at Facebook from the
records that we've been able to see we
have an example of a woman who worked
for the CDC who used her personal
Twitter account Twitter gave her through
her personal Twitter account the ability
to log in in flag misinformation and
disinformation and they actually
encouraged her to do it because they
said it was the best way to get
something like that reviewed which the
the that in that case being the post and
the information they determined were
misinformation so look it's it's it's
that's just the top of the layer of the
onion though there's so many layers
beneath it between intergovernmental
organizations non-governmental
organizations non-profit set up there's
a whole kind of regime that was built up
around this misinformation
disinformation uh you know thing and
they're using the government they're
using the powers of government and they
were using the powers of one of the
biggest social media platforms out there
to objectively Define for the American
people what was true and what was false
when people from the government would
flag something as dis or misinformation
is there are there instances where the
people at Twitter would say no it's not
and just ignore them so we haven't seen
yet and that's part of the problem is
that because these portals exist
some of these things are never going to
be disclosed from government records
this so is great for the government
actors to be able to do this because it
it obscures reality it is there's no
record to go back and check on if you
send an email or do something from a
government computer there's going to be
a record that you're going to be able to
go back and check but because they were
using a private platforms software
there's not going to be a way for us to
be able to determine how much they
actually flagged for these companies and
what the companies actually did with it
what we do have examples of are examples
of the private companies pulling down
content so we don't have examples yet
that I that I'm aware of that we've seen
where they've ever said oh hey no sorry
you know that we disagree with you on
this but we have seen examples of where
the private platforms have said yes
thank you we're happy to do that can you
can we do more for you what else can we
do for you government just in a really
shocking way that I think most Americans
would find truly offensive yeah I think
that there's a probably a tendency for
governments across the history of time
to hire external organizations to do
dirty work like mercenaries right um
things like that I just don't like
seeing it turned on the people
themselves by having government
officials use their private accounts to
have undocumented Communications with my
social media Network that I've been
using right right no I mean it's it's
exactly right it's like one of the
oldest plays in the book and the thing
about it is that of course the
government can't do that legally they
can't violate the First Amendment
through Contracting the work out to a
private company to do for them that's
that's against the law you can't do that
so there's there's gonna have to be some
real accountability here luckily there
are some things moving that hopefully
will bring that one of which being a
lawsuit that was filed by the states of
Missouri and Louisiana where they're
deposing folks right now I'm sure some
of your some of your viewers and
listeners have have been tracking that
that uh you know Elvis Chan was part of
this uh lawsuit he was just recently
deposed I think Jen saki's slated to be
deposed at some point actually getting
people in chairs asking them the
questions about what happened what was
going on here is going to be critical
and I you know we'll see what happens as
the result of the lawsuit but it should
shock the conscience of everyone
regardless of your perspective it should
shock your conscience that the
government would be able to do this
especially when you look at what they
were saying was false in a lot of cases
later became actually hey actually that
wasn't false and so this meaning of
Truth this divorced reality of what's
true and what's false you know is an
evolving thing for the for the
government and for the for the left
collectively and it leads to a place
where you can be censored as long as
you're just not agreeing with what the
what the current woke thought is and in
in with with covid stuff it was all over
the place we all lived it we lived it
for about two years think about how
crazy the the legal system is in terms
of perjury like what we've learned the
true extent of it
I I think perjury is a non-existent
thing at this point because what we have
here is uh you know Mr Dorsey do you
Shadow ban we don't you don't no you you
don't remove people that their knowledge
we visibility filter
so what
did you did what did you say the other
day I don't know if it was you was like
did you stab this man no I placed a
knife inside his body that was Luke he
put his chest all around my blade
do you have a door to your building no
we have a portal and and there is a a
vertical uh slat of wood with a a grip
on it so semantic dodging semantics is a
form of perjury I think we can be clear
about that Anthony fauci said they
didn't do gain a function James Clapper
said he had no winning knowledge of
spying on the American people even
though prism showed that they did yeah
right yeah he's like we we didn't do
gain of function research what we did
was manipulate viruses to make them more
deadly and dangerous it's like and
transmissible to human beings and then
ramp that's what the same exact one that
just naturally got out there because
someone ate a bat in China Rand Paul
holds up the paper and he's like uh it
says right here that you were doing gain
of function and he goes no it says on
the paper no
and there's and what and where's fauci
he's on MSNBC and they're like I can't
believe Elon would say prosecute fauci I
can he lied to Congress man look when it
comes to this stuff they all just lie we
watch them lie we know they're lying
they know we know they're lying we know
they know we know they're lying and
we're all just staring at each other
like nothing will change people get
charged people get charged for lying
under oath people get charged for lying
to Congress look what happened to Oliver
Stone he went down he went to jail
because he lied to Congressman well I
thought you could do it Brendan could do
it come on let's let's play fair here
let's actually hold people accountable
to what they said to how they lied to
the American people and how they screwed
them over oh you're talking about Roger
Stone not Oliver sorry I apologize
Oliver Ollie Oliver Stone great we
should have on the machine we should
have yeah I interviewed him before too
uh I don't always agree with him
fascinating guy he interviewed Putin has
a lot of context uh specifically about
Russia and Venezuela that I uh
definitely see differently than him but
it would be great to have him on the
show and have that conversation the
reason my apologies from my mistake yeah
Oliver uh the reason we have a
government for the People by the people
is because if the people that we put in
charge start lying to us we're supposed
to remove them from office and then
maintain balance and honesty and
integrity in our system maybe the whole
system has always been predicated on
lies maybe yes and you we just want to
close our eyes and believe that they're
doing the right thing when we put them
in power to lie for us you know I I
probably I imagine it like this
pre-radio you had
um people who hung out in their own
communities talk to each other and trust
each other and they did not trust for
the most part centralized media you know
distribution the printing press
relatively new in the you know uh
new-ish in the in the in the you know
before the American Revolution then they
started using this to put out propaganda
being like we should be independent it
affects people they hear it but for the
most part your life is still very much
oh I'm gonna do it the Patriot with Mel
Gibson what a good movie
they're they're you know in their house
and then a postal writer comes they're
like it's a there's a letter whoa like
words come from town
when gathers around
her
it's like I get 50
being on Twitter but so back then you
believed what you believed or you didn't
you saw what you saw you didn't and
there was no centralized communication
grid then you got radio and TV and all
of a sudden well actually even before
that you had the massive National
Distribution of newspapers which started
you know started getting really really
big in the late 1800s and then the turn
of the century everyone's now believing
the papers then everyone's believing the
radio then everyone's believing the TV
and it's all centralized and it was
probably all lies
but we believed it because that's what
we were told the radio the internet
comes out and we once again are
decentralizing our flaw of information
and we're getting into this
revolutionary period I guess
the uh the radio changed it all it did
because I remember Orson Welles did that
War of the Worlds radio show and people
actually believed it was real that
aliens were attacking it was so
believable on the radio there's this new
technology they went outside I heard
that people killed themselves because
they thought we were under attack by
aliens I don't know if that's confirmed
but then the then video comes or film uh
and film allows the centralization of
power for Hitler like Hitler is the
result of that centralization of Power
with that mass media mind control
technique now we have the internet and
it's like a we have both centralization
and decentralization kind of
at odds or or coming at each other and
trying to figure out the best way to
have like localized decentralized
centralized systems well this is why you
end up with uh who is that woman who did
the musical number about disinformation
you know what I'm talking about
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah this is why you
get these people right because they know
they're lying it's why you get people
like Taylor Lorenz and Ben Collins they
know they're lying of course they do
they they know they're making up things
but they're doing it in service of the
authoritarian narrative machine
these are people who long for a world
where like like uh was it Mika
Brzezinski said is that I say her name
Amiga Micah where she said it's our job
to tell people what to think she was
like Trump thinks he can tell people to
think that's our job and then Snopes
immediately comes out to debunk the
claims she said it when she literally
said but that's not what you mean what
they want is they want to go on TV and
say the sky is red and then have
everyone be like whatever you say boss
and the problem is now with the internet
we all start posting online well the sky
can be read sometimes depending on the
sunset but for the most part it's blue
so they're actually just manipulating
you and then someone says you're so dumb
this guy is red it's seven it's 7 pm at
Sunset it's like dude I know and then
you argue but that argument is part of
the Nuance in the conversation they
don't want they want to say no it's red
stop talking about it anybody who thinks
the sky is blue report to your education
center
gotta know that people are not we are
not built to fall in line I mean there's
part of us that work we're definitely
community based organisms but we're not
like you can't force people into slavery
it doesn't make sense it never has
worked in the history of humanity we've
always come away from it for a while
well you know if you look at human
history there's a lot of slavery there's
a lot of War there's a lot of
Destruction there's people like Genghis
Khan there's individuals that try to
conquer the world and control all of it
and try to uh have all of it for
themselves so so that's common that
always has happened and for us to think
that this has gotten this has somehow
left the the The Human Experience it's I
think it's foolish and I think there's a
lot of other smarter people out there
that are still going for these same
goals we just don't know about them we
don't hear about them and they're going
for these larger uh Personal Achievement
achievements for themselves in secret
it's like the the spirit of Moses is to
free the slaves and like the spirit of
the United States the Statue of Liberty
is a freed slave and they but the
businessmen that got the Statue of
Liberty put up there didn't want to show
the chains on her wrists they were like
no we can't remind people that we're
free we want them to forget they're on
our feet right yeah so they put the
chains down at her feet where you can't
see it because you're looking up at it
but if you look at it from above you see
broken chains she's a freed slave the
French understand Liberty as the United
as the Americans do but the businessmen
don't they don't like that they want us
to lull back into just worshiping some
erudite they want us to think oh she's
studied so she's great no she's great
because she was a freed slave she will
never go back is it isn't it like
everybody's related to Genghis Khan or
something or like
of the world I think is because he was
banging a lot of chicks you know yeah he
was going around taking Villages and
taking the women I think it's like
one-third in Asia everybody I think like
it's like history we go into slavery and
then we come out of it and then we go
back into it we come out of it and we're
trying to remind ourselves not to go
back into it yeah that's the story of
America of the United States do not fall
back into monarchy do not fall back
under the subservience of one man in a
corporation don't do it it's it's not
you know I don't know if monarchy is the
right word but we've Fallen at something
new we haven't yet defined right so we
have these words to describe things that
we probably didn't describe when they
were initially conceived of when
feudalism first came into existence
there wasn't some guy who looked around
and went this is feudalism you know it
was it was like the way things were and
then eventually we start to Define these
things so whatever and we're in now it
is not democracy it is not
constitutional republicanism something
totally different I mean it could just
be uh
a quasi you know revolutionary state
where you've got as as we've talked
about in the show a multicultural
democracy trying to exist within a
constitutional republic and they're both
at odds with each other and so they're
conflicted but it's certainly not one of
the other and you can't describe it that
way maybe we'll uh corporate
technagopoly yeah we'll we'll come up
with some new word for it like communism
was a word that was coined fascism was a
word that was a coin can we make up a
new word for whatever it is we're going
through thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time